Ce n'est pas facile.
Voila, maintenant ...
Esther Frey
wanderte aus idealistischen Gründen
nach Burkina Faso aus.
Das westafrikanische Land
zählt zu den ärmsten der Welt.
Noch immer brennt in ihr
das Feuer der 68er-Bewegung.
Wie sehen Sie Ihr Engagement hier an?
Als etwas ganz Natürliches:
Solidarität unter Menschen.
Wenn man genug für sich hat,
ist man verpflichtet zu geben.
* Lachen *
Wie erlebt Esther Frey
den Alltag in ihrer Wahlheimat?
Welchen Gefahren
setzt sich die Schweizerin aus?
Und worin findet sie ihre Erfüllung?
Davon handelt diese Reportage.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Diese Geschichte
beginnt 2015 in Zürich.
Das ist auch Kreis 4.
Der Zürcher Kreis 4
war für die studierte Psychologin
jahrzehntelang ihr Zuhause.
Das war mein Quartier.
Es ist nicht mehr dasselbe.
Eines der lustigen alten Häuser
wurde abgerissen.
Ich glaube, da entsteht zum Glück
ein Hiltl, was mir entgegenkommt.
Aber sonst fühle ich mich,
auch wenn es ein lebendiges, tolles
Quartier ist, nicht mehr zu Hause.
Beruflich war sie
v.a. im Personalbereich tätig.
Nach ihrer Pensionierung will sie
nun zu neuen Ufern aufbrechen.
Wenn das kein Schlaraffenland ist!
Sie wollen es trotzdem verlassen?
- Ja.
Warum?
- Irgendwann ist man einfach satt.
Ich konnte aus dem Vollen schöpfen
und ich habe das sehr genossen.
Jetzt finde ich, dass ich
nicht mehr so weitermachen kann,
wenn ich nicht mehr arbeite.
Dann wäre ich nur noch
ein Konsumtrottelchen -
das möchte ich nicht sein.
Hinter Esther Frey
liegen bewegte und engagierte Jahre.
Als Kind der 68er-Bewegung
war sie stets politisch aktiv.
Sie war Mitgründerin der Gruppe
für eine Schweiz ohne Armee.
* Rascheln *
Schön hinstellen.
Ihren Idealen
ist sie zeitlebens treu geblieben.
Ich hätte nie
irgendwo angestellt sein können,
wo man es mit Waffen oder der Armee
zu tun gehabt hätte.
Ich hätte auch in keiner Grossbank
arbeiten wollen.
Ich habe sehr darauf geachtet,
was ich auch innerhalb
der Gesellschaft
mit meiner Tätigkeit bewirke.
Diese Wohnung ist schon
über 35 Jahre lang ihr Zuhause.
Eine zeitlang lebte die kinderlose
Frau hier mit ihrem Partner zusammen.
Die Ehe mit dem Nigerianer
ging in die Brüche.
Aber ihre Liebe zu Afrika
ist geblieben.
* Rascheln *
Haben Sie auch
eine afrikanische Seele?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich habe sie durch 30 Jahre
afrikanischen Tanz entwickelt,
und durch 20 Jahre zusammenleben
mit einem Afrikaner.
Ich glaube schon,
dass ich dort die afrikanischen
Anteile meiner Seele stärken konnte.
Ihr Idol ist ein Revolutionsführer
aus Burkina Faso.
Dorthin will sie auswandern.
Die Wohnung
hat sie bereits gekündigt.
Das ist ein herziges, altes Buffet
mit Glaseinsätzen.
So hatte ich es schon als Kind.
Die Wohnung war auch deshalb
für mich sehr gemütlich.
Und jetzt heisst es,
Abschied nehmen davon.
* Trommeln *
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Drei Jahre später - 2018.
In der Stadt Koudougou
in Burkina Faso
hat sich Esther Frey inzwischen
ein stattliches Haus bauen lassen.
Ihre Oase steht inmitten eines
von Armut geprägten Quartiers
und kostete rund 100'000 Fr.
Das Anwesen wirkt wie ein Magnet
für die Menschen der Umgebung.
Tu as deja eu.
* Rascheln *
So, ein Säcklein pro Kind reicht.
Das ist ihr Frühstück.
Voici pour vous.
Attends! Attends! Attends! Attends!
Sie sind quasi
die Ernährerin des Quartiers?
Das ist zu viel gesagt.
Aber ich bin schon
für die Nachbarschaft da.
Und, äh ...
Wir haben hier viele Nachbarn,
die wirklich in der Misere sind.
Man weiss von Tag zu Tag nicht,
was sie essen.
(Kind) Merci.
- Bonne journee.
Bye-bye.
Das Spielzeug
gehört nicht in den Mund!
Bien jouer. Bye-bye.
Wer schliesst die Tür?
Rund 300 Fr.
gibt sie monatlich für sich aus.
Das ermöglicht der 67-Jährigen
für hiesige Verhältnisse
ein Leben in Luxus.
Fliessendes Wasser, wie ich es
hier mit dem Lavabo habe,
ist ein absoluter Luxus.
Das, ähm, haben wirklich ...
Das hat nur die Mittelschicht.
Hier im Quartier habe ich das
noch bei niemandem gesehen.
Es ist natürlich klar,
dass Sie die Leute anziehen
mit dem Lebensstandard,
den Sie sich leisten können.
Ja, schon, aber ich sichere mich
schon etwas ab.
In die Küche lasse ich niemanden.
Ich sage allen,
dass sie draussen warten sollen.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass sie das sehen.
Das würde mir wehtun.
Jene Kinder,
die am Morgen Erdnüsschen wollten,
sagten, sie möchten auch Orangen.
Wenn ich anfange ...
Ich kann nicht alle
auf meinem Standard ernähren.
Das ist ein Lernprozess.
Es ist schwierig zu wissen,
wer wirklich was nötig hat
und wer ist einfach nur zu faul,
um sich etwas zu erarbeiten.
Ihre direkten Nachbarn zum Beispiel.
Sie könnten mehr aus ihrem Leben
machen, ist Esther Frey überzeugt.
Bonjour, bonjour!
Immer wieder bringt sie ihnen
etwas zu Essen.
Condiment!
Jetzt kochst du damit etwas Feines.
Diesmal gibt sie dem Ehepaar
mehr als nur Gemüse.
Sie hält den beiden
auch eine Moralpredigt.
Warum pflanzt du keinen Baum hier?
Dieser Hof gehört deinem Onkel,
und du wartest darauf,
dass er kommt,
um einen Baum zu pflanzen.
Du kannst das doch selber machen.
Der Alkohol macht dich passiv.
Man ist ein bisschen hier,
man trinkt, anstatt zu arbeiten.
Du musst hier einen Baum pflanzen.
* Sie spricht französisch. *
Ich hab nicht die Kraft dazu.
Blödsinn! Das ist nur der Alkohol,
der macht alles kaputt.
Ist der Alkohol hier
ein grosses Problem?
Ja, in der Schweiz ja auch.
Alkohol ist wirklich ... Er macht
die Leute kaputt, die Familie ...
Es passiert nichts mehr.
Il faut bien faire la cuisine.
* Lachen *
Bye-bye.
Ce n'est pas grave.
Vor der Haustür
trifft sie auf einen weinenden Bub.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a?
Ce n'est pas grave.
Hat er dich geschlagen?
Du warst böse mit ihm.
Warum hast du ihn geschlagen?
Geh weg vom Sand!
Va la-bas, quitte la-bas!
Sie können auch schimpfen,
wenn es sein muss.
Ja, ja. Man muss schreien
wie in einem Wald voller Affen,
sonst geht man unter.
Der Alltag ist hart und einfach.
Nachbarschaftshilfe
ist lebenswichtig.
Konkret von dieser Nachbarin
habe ich Hilfe erhalten,
als ich das erste Mal
an Malaria erkrankt war.
Sie hat gesehen,
dass ich hohes Fieber hatte.
Am Abend sagte sie, sie könne mich
nicht alleine lassen,
sie schlafe bei mir.
Sie hat mich
während der Krankheit überwacht.
Viele andere
haben mir Früchte gebracht.
Wenn man krank ist,
muss man sich beinahe wehren,
dass man nicht zu viele Besucher
hat, die einem helfen wollen.
Esther ist eine wirkliche Schwester
für mich.
Seit ich sie kenne,
sind wir zusammen.
Wenn ich ein Problem habe,
hilft sie mir.
Umgekehrt mache ich für sie,
was ich kann.
Aber ich weiss,
dass sie viel mehr macht als ich.
* Im Hintergrund läuft Musik. *
Ihr Denken und Handeln ist vollkommen
geprägt durch die 68er-Bewegung.
Klassenkampf, Kommunismus, Freiheit.
Vieles sieht sie heute anders.
Aber von einer besseren Welt
träumt sie noch immer.
Was noch gleich geblieben ist ...
Ich möchte immer noch
grundsätzliche Veränderungen
in dieser materialistischen,
egoistischen Gesellschaft.
Es gibt wenig Solidarität.
Das finde ich hier in Burkina Faso.
Es geht um die Solidarität
von Mensch zu Mensch.
Der Mensch
sollte im Mittelpunkt stehen,
nicht das materielle Wachstum.
Ihr grosses Vorbild
ist Thomas Sankara.
Als linker Revolutionär
kam er 1983 in Burkina Faso
durch einen Staatstreich
an die Macht.
Er lehnte eine Rückzahlung
der Schulden der Dritten Welt
an den Westen ab.
Er begründete eine ambitionierte
Gesundheits- und Frauenpolitik.
1987 putschte ihn
ein Weggefährte aus dem Amt.
Sankara wurde dabei getötet.
Sie verehren Thomas Sankara.
Legitimieren Sie Gewalt
dann ein wenig,
wenn jemand an die Macht kommt
und Gutes fürs Volk machen möchte?
Nein,
Gewalt ist für mich nie legitimiert.
Wenn eine Geschichte ...
Gewalt ist einfach allgegenwärtig
und findet statt.
Wenn aus der Gewalt heraus
etwas Gutes entsteht, umso besser.
Aber für mich ist Gewalt
nie legitimiert.
Eine Bürgerwehr
unterwegs in Burkina Faso.
Solche Bilder sind im westafrika-
nischen Land alltäglich geworden.
Terroranschläge und Raubüberfälle
haben seit dem Militärputsch
vor vier Jahren zugenommen.
Die Nachbarschaftspatrouillen
sind eine Reaktion auf
die mangelnde Präsenz der Polizei.
Die Gewalt hat auch Esther Freys
Bekanntenkreis erreicht.
Ihr Kollege Nebo Basson
ist noch immer traumatisiert.
Denn vor ein paar Monaten
erschoss ein Mann ein Kind.
Daraufhin
verfolgte ihn die Bürgerwehr.
Der Täter versteckte sich dann
ausgerechnet im Haus von Nebo Basson.
* Er spricht französisch. *
Ich habe mein Velo hier abgestellt.
Dann ging ich zum Eingang.
Als ich mein Zuhause betrat,
hörte ich ein Geräusch.
Jemand stand hinter der Tür.
Als ich mich umdrehte, attackierte
mich ein Mann mit dem Messer.
Oui. Et c'etait directement la.
Er stach hier hinein.
Basson wurde schwer verletzt.
Er überlebte nur, weil Esther Frey
ihm die Operation bezahlte.
Esther bedeutet mir alles.
Sie ist meine Mutter.
Sie ist meine Retterin.
Mich musste man schon oft retten.
Der Täter flüchtete und wurde noch
im Dorf von der Bürgerwehr gestellt.
Nach einer Schiesserei waren er
und drei weitere Personen tot.
Trotz zunehmender Gewalt
in Burkina Faso:
Esther Frey lässt sich
ihren Idealismus nicht nehmen.
Nein, denn es sind Wellen,
die vielleicht wieder vorüberziehen.
Wir alle hoffen, dass sich eine
neue Gesellschaft einrichten kann,
dass es Geburtswehen sind.
Sie leben mit diesem Risiko?
Ja.
Leben und sterben gehören zusammen.
Sie sagen selbst,
die Gewalt habe zugenommen.
Ja, weltweit.
Hier kann man versuchen,
sich gegenseitig zu schützen.
Man hat gesehen: Sie haben sich
verteidigt. Man kann damit leben.
Die Menschen hat man gleich
an jener Stelle begraben,
wo sie umgebracht wurden.
Und jetzt müssen ein paar Häuser
wegen des Vorfalls abgerissen werden.
Nach altem Brauch
muss man den Hof verlassen,
wenn darauf Blut geflossen ist.
Das Gelände ist verflucht
und bringt der Familie Unglück.
Nebo Basson kann heute
wieder als Tanzlehrer arbeiten.
Einmal in der Woche
ist auch Esther Frey mit dabei.
Afrikanischer Tanz
ist schon seit 30 Jahren ihr Hobby.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Die Gemeinschaft
ist ihre Familie geworden.
Unabhängig zu bleiben
ist ihr aber ebenso wichtig.
Deshalb ist das Thema Partnerschaft
für sie abgeschlossen.
Ihr Zuhause
ist von einer Mauer umgeben.
Sie schützt aber nur bedingt
vor unerwünschtem Besuch.
Ich muss alles abschliessen.
Wann immer ich einen Raum verlasse,
muss ich ihn mit dem Schlüssel
abschliessen.
Es gab mehrere Diebstähle.
Insgesamt sind es jetzt fünf.
Aber es war nur zweimal davon
wirklich schwierig.
Einmal kam der Computer weg
und einmal,
als die Bankkarten weg waren.
Sonst waren es Geldbeträge,
die zu verschmerzen waren.
Die Diebstähle beschäftigen sie.
Dagegen will sie etwas unternehmen.
Etwas für Europäer
eher Aussergewöhnliches.
* Afrikanischer Gesang
aus dem Autoradio. *
Es geht nach Sabou.
Das Dorf liegt rund 25 km entfernt
von Esther Freys Wohnort Koudougou.
Im See am Ortsrand von Sabou
wimmelt es von Krokodilen.
Sie gelten als heilig.
Eines der Reptilien
soll der Schweizerin helfen,
sie vor Diebstählen zu bewahren.
Und das geht so:
Wird das Huhn vom Krokodil gefressen,
geht der Wunsch in Erfüllung.
So besagt es
die jahrhundertealte Legende.
Darf ich fragen,
was Sie nun vorhaben?
Ich habe dem Huhn
meinen Wunsch mitgeteilt.
Er macht jetzt ...
Er ruft die Krokodile an,
damit sie meinen Wunsch erfüllen.
* Der Mann spricht afrikanisch. *
Se passe de cette cote?
Wenn Sie das Ritual machen,
sind Sie auch überzeugt,
dass es funktioniert?
Dass Ihr Wunsch in Erfüllung geht.
Bringt man Geld zur Bank, hofft man
auch, dass es dort sicher ist.
Wissen tut man es nie.
Aber Sie glauben es?
Ich hoffe darauf.
Ein Krokodil, das schon Tausende
von Jahren auf der Welt ist,
weiss vielleicht gleich viel
über die Welt wie wir.
* Esther Frey singt
ein afrikanisches Lied. *
Das Lied
ist ein alter afrikanischer Ahnenruf,
um mit dem Jenseits
in Kontakt zu kommen.
Die Rentnerin beschäftigt
sich oft mit dem Älterwerden
und der Vergänglichkeit allen Lebens.
Das ist der Friedhof
von unserem Quartier Secteur 9.
Ich hoffe, dass auch ich
dereinst hier beerdigt werde.
In Burkina heisst es dann:
"Que la terre te soit legere."
Dass die Erde dir leicht sei.
Sie wollen
auf keinen Fall je zurückgehen?
Auch nicht, wenn es Ihnen im Alter
gesundheitlich nicht so gut geht?
Sie möchten
hier in Burkina Faso sterben?
Ich denke, das ist für mich
die Flucht vor dem Altersheim.
Das ist jener Ausweg,
von dem ich das Gefühl habe,
dass ich hier besser aufgehoben bin,
um solange wie möglich
gesund zu sein
und dann möglichst bald zu sterben.
Angenommen, Sie brauchen Pflege.
Sind Sie sicher,
dass zu Ihnen geschaut wird?
Ich überlasse das dem Schicksal.
Ich bin überzeugt,
ich habe hier Leute,
die mich genauso liebevoll pflegen
werden, wie ich mit ihnen umgehe.
Das ist z.B. etwas, das mich rührt:
so ein einfaches Grab.
Und es steht nur:
"Repose en paix, maman."
Und ... es ist so allgemein.
Es ist nicht das Individuum.
Es ist einfach eine Mutter,
die geehrt wird.
Das ist etwas,
was ich sehr schön finde.
Natürlich hofft Esther Frey
auf ein langes Leben.
Deshalb will sie sich
auch gesund ernähren.
So konnte sie
eine Bauernfamilie überzeugen,
Biogemüse anzubauen.
Das ist nun
für meinen Eigenverbrauch.
Das ist ein Vorprojekt.
Wenn ich finde,
die Qualität ist gut,
die Sachen können auch einem er-
weiterten Publikum verkauft werden,
dann suche ich v.a. Restaurants,
die Abnehmer wären.
So könnte dieser Familienbetrieb
Gemüse verkaufen.
Wenn das richtig läuft,
verdienen Sie dann auch daran?
Sicher nicht! Ich möchte,
dass die Familie daran verdient.
Esther Frey träumt nicht nur
von einer besseren Welt,
sie will sich eine solche
auch erschaffen.
Die Arbeit
wird ihr wohl nie ausgehen.
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *